first rugby league today became the
latest sport to ban transgender athletes
from competing against women swimming's
governing body voted on sunday to bar
trans women in a world athletics
ascendant it could be next so with the
tide finally turning back to what i
would call common sense i'm joined now
by fox news contributor an olympian kate
lynch caitlin great to talk to you
hello pierce it's been so long we
haven't had a chance to talk but anyway
it's always good to talk to you pierce
what's great what do you what do you
need to know here's what i need to know
i i sort of feel that you and i have
been two people
part of a lonely group who for quite
some time have been begging the sports
authorities to well for one of a better
phrase grow a pair and actually do
something about this iniquity who's been
created with trans athletes competing
against women born to
female biological bodies finally
that seems to be happening what's your
reaction
yeah um i honestly i think it's very
good um to be honest with you pierce i
have been on this issue from the
beginning i've been very consistent i
have said from day one i don't want
biological boys
to be competing against women especially
in school
and honestly it's just not fair and we
need to protect women's sports
and i've stuck with that all the way
through
but i think what that did is it gave
the international liberty committee
who basically last november gave the
authority to the different sports
organizations
throughout the world to come up with
their own reforms
and nema which is controls world
swimming
they were the first ones to do it and i
think there's going to be a lot to
follow uh but basically saying that if
you have gone through male puberty
because they had a lot of sciences talk
about male puberty to the board before
they voted um that it is no matter what
your hormone levels are down the line it
makes a big it's a big advantage um to
any trans woman who has been through
male puberty it's a tremendous advantage
so because of that
they voted
71.5 percent of the board
voted
to change the rules so now if you have
gone basically through male puberty they
are saying before the age of 12
uh you can't compete in in swimming at
the girl with women um and honestly i
think that's the right decision uh we
need to protect
women's sports um and i think this will
have a big impact on it yeah i agree
just on this yeah well i'll tell you
just on this yeah go but your guy
sebastian coe i read an article today
uh he's with uh track and field uh with
the olympic committee
they're looking into the exact same set
of rules
we have got a clip of lordco actually
talking about this let's play the clip
maintaining the
primacy and the integrity of female
competition is absolutely vital if it's
a judgment between inclusion and
fairness
we will always fall down on the side of
fence
what's fascinating about this is how
divisive it remains as an issue so megan
repino probably the most famous female
football soccer star in america and
probably the world actually uh multiple
world champion she came out and said
this show me the evidence that trans
women are taking everyone's scholarships
are dominating in every sport winning
every title i'm sorry it's just not
happening we need to start from
inclusion period as things arise i've
confidence we can figure it out but we
can't start at the opposite it's cruel
and frankly it's just disgusting uh she
said we're putting everything through
god forbid a trans person be successful
in sports get a grip on reality and take
the step back
what i don't understand about it if i
was interviewing megan rapino i'd be
saying look
i remember when the women's american
soccer team the best in the world by
miles the best has ever been led by
megan rapino played a bunch of 15 year
old boys at soccer and they got beat
they got beaten 5-2 i think which shows
you what happens if you don't separate
the sexes when it comes to any physical
sport
you know what um i honestly i think this
is a good decision you know leah thomas
from the beginning i've never had a
problem with her
she has played by the rules
it was the rules that were wrong the
ncaa rules that let her compete
and i have been
actually at this point now to see what
happens
i'm actually happy she did this why she
brought this issue forward and
world soccer or world uh
swimming
has made a decision and i think it's the
right decision so i'm thankful for leah
thomas um she changed everything uh and
this is this is a good thing for women's
sports but what about megan repino's
comments
what about what what about megan
repino's view which is you should
include all trans athletes in women's
sport but it's actually they're not
dominating so why are we all making such
a fuss about it
well first of all they talk about having
this
uh a different uh division for trans
athletes
pierce
there's not enough trans athletes in the
world to have a different
to have another competition right now i
only know of one uh trans swimmer and
that's leah thomas um and they just
there's not enough people out there they
i think they did it was kind of like a
whitewash of oh you know we're banning
uh the leah thomases of the world the
the trans athletes who have been through
male puberty uh but we're going to have
this little bone out there oh we're
going to create a different division
honestly
appears there's not enough trans people
in the world to have it but in a way
in a way that's kind of what megan
repino is saying that there aren't many
trans athletes who can compete at the
moment at an elite level so therefore we
should just we shouldn't be we shouldn't
be banning them
what do you say to her specific point
uh no it's not that we shouldn't be
banning it we need to we need to it's
not about banning trans athletes
it's about protecting
women
sports let's make it keep that playing
field fair and balanced for women look
at all the things that women have been
through over the last few years back in
the 80s title ix here in the united
states huge huge
opportunity for equality in sports for
women and they got it and now they can
get scholarships they can get this
why would we set it back let's just keep
it clean there's other things that trans
women or trans men they can compete in
intramural sports they can compete in
co-ed sports on a different level they
don't have to be at the high level so
let's keep it fair let's protect women's
sports well i'll separate you katelyn i
noticed yesterday uh on your instagram
we shared a story of kim kardashian and
kylie jenner both sent you flowers on
father's day with a note yes and i think
kim actually posted something um
praising you as a step-dad
um
i guess for you is it is it confusing
does it feel perfectly normal they call
you still a stepdad that you're still
their father how do you feel about it
my kids are the absolute best i'm the
luckiest parent in the world to have
children like this
um
especially kendall and kylie
you know when the first when i went
through this years ago seven years ago
they said well you know dad what do we
call you and i thought for a second i
said dad
um i'm your father i've always been your
father i'll always be your father i will
die your father so i have no problem
with you whatsoever calling me dad
okay and that's just the way it is and
they have been very good at that but
what they're even better at
is even when they talk about their dad
they always go their dad she did this
they changed pronouns right in the
middle and every time i hear it my dad
she
i'm like blown away how smart my kids
are and how respectful they are of my
wishes because i'm i'm their father i'm
certainly not their mother i wouldn't
it's disrespectful to their mother
um which i i'm not that type of person
uh but i'm i've always been their dad
and i'll be their dead until the day
they die so uh call me dad but they do
change pronouns my dad she does this my
dad she does that well jealousy in a way
is the kind of accommodation i think it
makes a lot of sense and takes a lot of
the heat out of this debate people can
just be a little bit giving on both on
both sides right
yes first of all pierce you know me i'm
a common sense person i'm not into all
this oh my gosh though pronouns and this
and people my mother
calls me by the wrong she's 96 years old
she'll every once in a while slipped
when she's in the middle of an argument
you know superman bruce you got to do
this
i don't even say anything i don't care
the bottom line is
i'm happy i wake up in the morning every
morning and i just be myself all day
long that is the best feeling in the
world i don't have to lie to anybody i
don't have to misrepresent myself to
anybody i just have to be me and because
of that it's allowed me to go out and do
other things in business like actually
i'll be in the uk here
not this weekend next weekend is a
british grand prix
i have two cars in the w series uh one
is a brit jamie chadwick yes um who's
won the first three races uh she's on
jenner racing and i have a young girl
named chloe chambers who's only 17 years
old great young driver coming up and
we'll be i'll be out at silverstone uh
at the british grounds you're coming in
cheering on my girls well if you're
coming into my country kate i'd like to
invite you to come and see me in the
studio here we'll have a cup of tea
together maybe do an interview about
something nothing to do with trans just
other stuff yeah what about that yeah no
i do do so many other we got to get off
the trans thing right uh i i have been
an avid i have been an avid race car
driver for uh for 30 years i did it
professionally uh have enjoyed it and
was given the opportunity to uh own two
cars
caleb i've got to wrap it up but when
you're here come come and see me let's
have a cup of tea okay
let's talk about boris johnson donald
trump whatever you like
i'll see what we can do and looking
forward to seeing you brilliant i look
forward to welcoming you to this fine
country caitlyn jenner always a pleasure
to talk to you speaker always you speak
such common sense i appreciate it
thank you
you